Donna Griffit, thank you so much
for joining me.
How are you?
I'm great.
Thank you so much, Michael.
I just read,
when somebody asks you,
"These days, how are you?"
You're supposed to say,
"Well, I'm 2020 great."
which means
... life is pretty good,
cannot complain.
Well, we're going to talk soon about
how actually during covid
you accelerated your business
to over 150% growth,
but we're gonna leave that
to the later half of the conversation,
because I'd like to start off
with your journey.
Donna, you're a worldwide known
storyteller. You've helped
thousands of entrepreneurs,
founders, CEOs, executives
work through their stories.
And the way that you're saying it
is to turn raw data
into something meaningful and magical
that others buy into and engage with.
It's never been more relevant than today,
and I think that
as I'm watching the world unfold,
especially in terms
of politics and entrepreneurship,
it's all about storytelling
and it's all about framing.
But let's go from the beginning.
Donna, who are you?
Oh, wow. Who am I?
That's a trick question.
You could go anywhere with that.
So, I am a storyteller
through and through.
It's funny that sometimes
your professions find you.
So, I've been the polisher of diamonds,
as somebody called me,
for the past 16 years.
I love that, polisher of diamonds.
Just to give you an example,
yesterday, I had three two-hour meetings
where I wrote three investor decks.
One was for a company
doing data for blockchain exchanges.
Another one was a medical device
for repairing the heart valve.
And the third one was a marketplace
for artists to come home and do their art,
their cooking, their whatever.
So, I mean, that's what
my weeks look like.
I get to work with the best,
the brightest, the most amazing companies.
And what they all have in common,
other than the fact that they're brilliant,
is they all struggle to tell their story.
And sometimes
people hear storyteller they're
like, "What's that?"
And what it really is
is it's messages that compel.
When you're listening to a story,
you should be so engaged and enthralled
that you don't even feel a sense of time,
you're not distracted by other things,
you're synced completely to the speaker.
And when our wavelengths are synced up,
and there's actually studies that show
that storyteller and story listener
are synced up,
the influence is much bigger.
So, stories can really
catapult our business.
Why is it so hard?
Telling a story,
you start off with a beginning,
then you have a middle and an end,
you put a conflict in the middle,
and then you finish with a
Hollywood happy ending.
... so easy.
So, what I think it is
it's the, I call it the baby syndrome.
When you have a baby,
and people are like "So how's the baby?"
You pull out your phone
and you start showing
hundreds and hundreds of pictures,
and you're oblivious to the fact that
people are glazed over.
And you can receive the same
kind of fun effect by showing two or three
and be done with it.
Right.
So, the same thing with founders.
I feel that there's a lot of overtelling, overselling,
not being clear,
and they overwhelm their users.
So, I sometimes call it
it's like a first date.
Upon your first date,
you start talking about
your entire dating history,
where you want to get married,
how many kids you want to have.
There's a good chance
you're not gonna see that person again.
So, the same thing
with an investor or a salesman;
you want to give them
just what they need to know
to intrigue them and want them to go
on another date with you.
So, founders, executives,
everyone gets lost in the weeds.
And obviously, when you're meeting
these different founders and executives,
you're meeting them across
all different stages
of their life cycle, right,
from very early stage
to very late stage.
And I'm sure that the messaging
is also different in how they convey.
Some of them is more data driven,
some of that is more dreamlike
and let's go on a journey
of what the future could hold
for the world.
And you have to do that.
That, I think, is the key thing
that a lot of people miss
that investors really look for
is that North Star, that vision.
Ask yourself five years from now
what will your company be
for your industry or beyond your industry.
What are you changing,
what's the seismic shift
that's happening thanks to you?
And that's what you want to look towards.
What you're doing now
may just be the first step in that,
and that's fine.
You got to start somewhere,
but you need to be able
to paint the picture
of the much bigger journey.
100%.
So Donna,
you start off your life orthodox.
At 16, you know
what you're going to be doing
with your life.
Walk me back to your childhood.
I have to understand
how does one become an expert storyteller
to the point where
they're working with thousands
of entrepreneurs and executives?
So, yeah. My parents became orthodox.
We moved to Israel when I was 11,
and we became Orthodox
a few years before that,
and I spent many years back and forth
between Israel and the US.
I've always been a hybrid,
which at first as a kid
is very hard to take,
'cause when I moved to Israel,
I was like, Oh, she's so American.
And so, and you try to grow the skin
to be more robust.
And then I moved back
to get my master's at NYU
in drama therapy,
which is what I discovered at 16.
It's like they put together the perfect,
thankfully I knew
that there was a masters at NYU.
I knew that's what I wanted to do,
and everything I did up until then
was geared towards
getting into that program. And then at-
Drama therapy?
Drama therapy,
that's what my masters is in.
What's drama therapy?
It's a combination of psychology
and theatric arts.
My thesis was written about
the internship that I did
at Bellevue Hospital
with homeless, mentally ill adult men.
It was an inpatient program
that they were out of the hospital ward
and moving into.
So, I did six months there
just as 9/11 happened.
So, I experienced
what it was to be homeless
'cause we were evacuated on 9/11
and I lived ... Financial District.
So, it's one of those really
pivotal times in the world,
and here we are at another one.
So, stories become so powerful,
and my thesis was a lot about
the stories of how these men
were processing and dealing.
So, how did I get
to corporate storytelling
out of that?
I realized that I had always loved acting.
And I knew something in me,
I couldn't be an actress
if I wanted to be able
to put food on the table,
so I needed to find something
to combine it.
That was why drama therapy,
and then I discovered
the drama therapy salary
was about that of a struggling artist.
So, I started thinking,
"What else? What else?"
I enrolled in a post master's program
for training
and organizational development
after I had one of these "aha moments"
that somebody said they had a friend
that traveled the globe giving workshops.
And I was like,
"That's what I want to do with my life!"
So, I found that,
sent my resume
to the first place on Craigslist,
of all places,
that was looking for corporate trainers.
Craigslist, wow.
Yeah. And I was with
Boyer Communications Group,
a wonderful boutique firm
in New York for over 12 years.
Brett Boyer taught me everything I know.
He was like a father and a mentor.
And I learned on the job.
I traveled all around
giving these workshops.
And then transferred my skill set
to startup stories.
Unbelievable. Just unbelievable.
So, going back to startup stories,
walk me through
what a meeting with you would be like.
So, if I'm coming in and I'm saying,
"Donna, I have this big thing
that I have to do. I have to raise capital,
I have to go give a keynote
about my product,
I have a sales pitch
to this crazy company"
What does our engagement look like?
What does it mean
to work with a storyteller?
So, what happens is I send you
a cheat sheet for whatever,
if it's a sales deck, an investor deck,
a five minute pitch for a demo day,
and you organize your data.
It's almost like
I'm giving you a shopping list and saying
Please go to Whole Foods
or some high quality store,
bring me premium ingredients,
and I will cook you
the meal in the session.
So, everything happens in real time.
We have a two hour session,
we dive right in.
And I have a filter in my brain
that's backed by AI,
and ML and deep learning and NLP.
I have no idea what's in there,
but something happens
and out comes the story
and I start writing.
And it's very collaborative
'cause then the founder
sees what I'm writing,
and I stop and they say,
"Okay, that part's great.
That part we need to tweak a bit."
And then we iterate on the spot,
creating the optimal story
that they feel 150% confident about.
It's important to me
that I'm taking their voice
and elevating it.
People don't tend to write
about themselves in superlatives
and in braggadocios kind of ways,
which it's not a bad thing.
You need to be able
to show that confidence.
Let your numbers speak for yourself.
And so, it's getting into the right flow.
It's almost like
putting a puzzle together,
you have to move pieces around.
And like yesterday
I finished one of the sessions,
and then I was drinking coffee
and I'm like, lightning moment,
I know how to make it even better.
And I went back
and split one of the slides,
moved something around,
and cracked it all open.
So it's really fun, intense,
I mean ...
but we get things done, and usually
they leave after two hours
with a fully scripted deck.
Two hours. So, you know
people work for weeks
on slide decks and presentations,
iterating, getting feedback
from so many different people.
Sometimes, these are
the make or break moments
for the company, right?
If I'm taking my slide deck,
and I have an opportunity
to pitch in front of a top tier VC,
this is pretty much
my moment of glory, right?
Not just for the startup,
but also as me as a founder
this is a chance to position ourselves.
How do you get this done in two hours?
Because you're not necessarily
an expert in their field.
You don't necessarily know
these people personally.
I don't come from a technical background,
I don't come from a business,
a finance background.
I told you what my masters is in.
But I am able at the same time
to have a conversation between them
and whoever they're pitching to,
whether it's an investor
or potential customer,
think of all of the questions
the other side would have.
All of the objections,
and our goal is to bring those up
and to mount them as we tell the story,
as we go through the message so that
they're not sitting there thinking,
... they're sitting there thinking ...
So, we really want to engage them
and answer their questions,
which really is what
storytelling is all about.
It's about engaging the other side
and what's important to them.
So, yeah.
That makes sense.
I don't know what it is,
that's just my superpower
to be able to chameleon myself in.
And I always say to them,
If I can tell your story, anybody can.
I'm the benchmark
of every man or every woman
that I'm gonna be
the lowest common denominator
you'd be speaking to.
And if I get it, they'll get it,
especially if they're from your field
or they have a deep understanding
of your field.
And what is the feedback loop?
So, you send them off,
they take the slide deck,
do they come back, update?
Sometimes they'll come back,
they'll send it to me for review,
and then sometimes they'll come back.
Like if they did the investor deck,
they'll raise,
and then we'll do the sales deck
or their website.
What's great is
once we've cracked the DNA
of their story in one deliverable,
they're able to then translate it
and weave it into others.
Right.
It's like their basis.
I call it the infrastructural messaging.
It's the things that's
gonna take them forward
5, 10 years.
It's the basis of their language,
which will evolve and change.
I mean, I worked with JFrog
when they were just a tadpole,
and now they're about to go public.
And they hired me after I coached them
... two-minute pitch session,
and nobody could understand
what the heck they were doing.
And they came to me afterwards
and they're like,
"Yeah, I think we your help"
So, we worked on their sales desk
and their pitch deck and they raised
their first four mil after that.
And it's so exciting to see
because they were true visionaries,
they were way ahead of the curve,
and nobody was getting it yet.
It's kind of like a lot of
the blockchain applications are now
and looking at data in blockchain.
Back then it was all big data
and continuous delivery,
nobody got it.
So, it's being able to help them
see into the future and understand
that this is gonna be a big thing.
That's a huge piece,
like we were talking about before, vision.
Of course. So, you've got to see
over the past years
the industry of storytelling.
And this is a very unique perspective,
I think, because as an entrepreneur
or as an executive,
you really get to see one story unfold
over and over
in front of different people
over a life cycle.
You get to
see thousands of different stories
unfold at different stages
across years.
Has the industry changed at all?
Are the expectations different
about storytelling
from, let's say, 10 years ago?
Yeah. Oh, yeah.
I mean, 10 years ago or 11 years ago
is when I pivoted
to working with startups,
and we were at a high trajectory
of a crisis, of a recession, where
how you told your story mattered more.
Here we are once again
at that kind of trajectory
where investors are investing,
but they're gonna invest
in whoever they think is gonna make
the best return for them at this time,
and you need to be able
to tell a good enough story
of why you why now.
I call that the silver bullet slide.
It has to be about why, the urgency,
get them to see
that this is something now.
So, I have a workshop that I give
on finding the villain,
the bad guy in your audience ...
whether it's economic turn down
or security vulnerabilities
or waste in the system.
That was a list I made
in about 2009, 2010.
I've now updated it
to look at the pain points
that have arisen. All of a sudden
overnight we were thrust into
a completely new reality
with completely new needs.
I mean, the fact that in the US
you couldn't get masks
and toilet paper and things
at the beginning is mind boggling.
So, something has to be done
with supply chain.
Kids are learning from home
and they're learning through
a medium like this, which is great,
but it's not very engaging.
I have a seven year old.
She's sitting in front of Zoom all day.
The teachers are doing
the best they can to engage them.
So, that's another part
that I'm gonna see
I see a lot of disruption.
So, smart investors
and smart entrepreneurs
know how to look at
where things are going and pivot.
And I've seen some amazing companies
pivot right away
when this whole thing started
and do extremely well.
Like see what's happening and then,
Okay, here's what we're gonna do.
Move fast.
So, covid hits.
You mentioned that you looked back at 2008,
a recession that you went through,
and now you've managed
to make some changes
in order to accelerate your business
in a time when you don't even
get to meet face to face
with those that you're helping
tell their story.
And to me it sounds so,
there's so much humanity
and so much personality in storytelling.
And I'm sure that when you're sitting
in a room with somebody
this energy and this chemistry,
it's part of the process, right,
of understanding each other.
And yet you managed
to even accelerate your business.
Tell me about that.
Well lucky for me,
I've been doing Zoom meetings like this
for many years.
I was already a happy paying
Zoom customer before covid hit.
So, I'm happy to have contributed
to their big 167% growth
over the past few months,
but I was already there before.
No, I'm not a stakeholder.
But what happened March 14,
starting to feel like
the bleep is hitting the fan,
emails from my girls' schools were closing.
We were living in an apartment complex,
they closed all shared spaces.
Clients canceling meetings
saying they couldn't pay for work
that was already done
like all at once.
And I was totally thrust back to 2008
when that was happening
at the same time.
And I was like,
"Okay, what am I gonna do? What am I gonna do?"
Of course, the first emotion
naturally is fear
and you can't breathe.
And then I was like,
"Okay, where's my 2008 playbook."
I grabbed it from the attic,
dusted it off, and I was like,
"Okay, what can I learn from there?"
That was the point where I pivoted
to working with startups,
because enterprise was crumbling
and startups had a need.
And of course,
all the lovely voices of people saying,
"Startups?
Nobody's gonna pay you for that."
...
So I mean, I was actually,
... one of those serendipitous moments
where I was introduced
to a cardiothoracic surgeon
who needed help
with his professional speeches,
but also had two medical devices
that he needed pitches for.
And that was my first foray
into the world.
And I actually went
and presented on his behalf
for a Big Angel conference,
saw the other startups
that were invited pitch,
and my heart just broke and I'm like,
"Someone needs to help them."
That was my moment of ...
I was actually the first person in Israel
to coin the phrase
storytelling for business or for startups.
And, not in the world.
And then, I was like,
"Okay, what do people need now?
What do they need
in the here and now?"
And I thought, okay,
we're all gonna be working from home.
People need remote presentation training,
because people don't know
how to present, they are awful.
So, I took out a presentation,
a workshop that I gave back in 2003
before we even had video conferences.
Reworked it, added a layer of Zoom,
and started marketing it.
The other thing ... I'm like
startups are gonna be
freaking out now.
So, I took one of my workshops
and broadened it and called it
"Fundraising For Uncertain Times"
Amazing.
So those two things, pushing it out,
creating visibility,
creating partnerships,
trying everything.
And in Hebrew we have the expression:
throw your bread out on the water.
Yup.
You never know who's gonna nibble.
Right.
And that's just what happened.
People nibbled. Amazing.
Donna, I have to say,
I mean it's amazing to me
how people work so hard
on such amazing technologies
for so long.
And sometimes it boils down
to a few minutes,
it boils down to a two-minute pitch
or a five-minute pitch
or even an hour pitch.
And you're trying to sum up
a work of years
in a 10-minute presentation.
And at the end, it's almost, I think,
an analogy to people go to the gym
three times a week, four times a week
to work on their body so much.
People don't really put too much effort,
most of the time, on their minds
and training their minds,
whether it be better sleep quality,
better food, psychology, whatever.
And I think it's a similar thing here, and
I think that the work that you're doing
is just so incredible
and I can't wait to work with you as well
when I have my own startup
and my own projects.
But before we leave,
I want to thank you for being
so generous with your time.
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Okay. So, optimist.
My motto for life is Winston Churchill.
Of course, I'm an optimist.
I don't see much point
in being anything else.
A get thing doner.
Getting s**t done.
That's the closest word I can find.
I am on it.
I love it.
No moss grows under my feet.
If I don't do it on the spot,
I feel like I'll never get it done.
And I'm a really good friend.
I'm a really good friend
and a really good spouse
and daughter. I mean
I'm very devoted to the people
that I care about in my life.
I love that.
Donna, toda raba.
Thank you very, very much.
This was just wonderful.
Have a great holiday weekend.
Take care.
Bye, Michael.